when we go on tour uh we always ask
about different people's writers and
yours comes up as like uh they say TJ
just wants you to get them like the most
[ __ ] craziest sandwich you could
possibly give them yeah I do for a while
it was a terrible turkey sandwich and I
said that was open to interpretation and
then also it was a a either a real
pinata or a hand-drawn picture of a
pinata
so that was really fun because when I
did that because I wanted to see how
much they were paying attention yeah but
also how into kind of does the club have
a sense of humor so what all the venues
start doing is each year they tried to
up their terrible turkey sandwich and
they would also compete against each
other and same with the pinata so
terrible turkey sandwich sometimes would
be like a whole roasted turkey with two
Triscuits you know in between two
triskets and they so they would do it
that big one person got me a tie the
tiniest turkey sandwich and then the
best of all I think was a pinata shaped
like a turkey sandwich and when you hit
it what came out was smaller hand-drawn
pictures of pinatas and Tiny turkey
sandwiches
that's kind of the most meta one you
know that's wow but yeah and then now I
asked for fresh flowers and then some
dead or dying flowers to remind me of my
imminent mortality and emergency
underwear
you never know Stevo you of all people
yeah you know that emergency underwear
can come in today
I I am he likes plaid boxers
I I only wear special underwear for the
show also well I I always wear plaid
boxers because there's just some times
when your butthole's itchy you know you
don't want to Edge it but your
butthole's just on a Tans and knees just
begging you for the edge yeah and then
but it's butt begging right and then
when you itch you when you hit you you
end up what's called a skid mark That's
why you have a yeah I'm familiar with it
the car lots
they call it a skid mark and uh I find
that the Plaid boxers uh most
effectively disguise of this kid Mark
you know you wouldn't even know it was
there you should do uh underwear with
skid marks all over it that's like Japan
and that's something you could do but I
could yeah imagine if I was like I'm
also staring underwear it looks like
he's wiped [ __ ] on it it's called skid
mark brand underwear that's not a bad
idea yeah it's not a bad idea at all
it's like coasters with like little
lines of coke as the art design yeah it
should be good too but right now these
skid marks is healthier for your fan
base right it's a skid mark you could
make it look really realistic too all
the different skid marks like I saw you
did that Mike Dyson Iron Man
you and I should do it we shouldn't
tattoo skin Mark diarrhea underwear on
our bodies but we could collab then drop
that skid mark so it's gonna be you know
five aren't available I think that clip
was awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what I've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions my first book's Five star
rated on Amazon and I have no doubt this
one will be too so get the autograph
copy right now at stevo.com
yeah dude